eran las cuatro y Trece de la tarde en
Estambul cuando sucedió esto en la
céntrica avenida isditlal muertos
heridos y caos;
estábamos un poco lejos pero vimos
algunas personas tiradas en el suelo fue
un sonido de explosión enorme y después
de eso se levantó humo negro más tarde
la gente comenzó a gritar
tras el ataque del gobierno Turco
prohibió a los medios locales emitir
imágenes o dar informaciones se
restringieron redes sociales como
Twitter YouTube o Instagram toda
comunicación quedó en manos del Estado
las unidades pertinentes en nuestro
estado Siguen trabajando para revelar
los autores de este ataque traicionero
los esfuerzos de apoderarse de Turquía y
la nación turca mediante el terrorismo
no alcanzarán su objetivo Ni hoy ni
mañana igual que ayer
desde el gobierno hablan de ataque
terrorista
pensamos que se trató de un acto de
terrorismo ocurrido en este cruce como
consecuencia de la detonación de una
bomba por parte de un atacante a quien
consideramos una mujer
esta sería la primera gran explosión de
una bomba en Estambul en años y todavía
no ha sido reivindicada en 2016 un
militante de estado islámico ya se había
hecho explotar en la misma Avenida
matando a cuatro turistas e hiriendo a
36 personas también en 2016 dos
atentados fuera de un estadio de fútbol
mataron a 38 personas se hirieron a 155
Entonces el ataque estuvo reivindicado
por la rama militar del partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán en esta
ocasión el partido democrático de los
pueblos vinculado con el grupo armado
kurdo también ha condenado el ataque